olá meu nome é evitar eu tenho 10 anos e
sou diabético tipo 1 desde 5 e hoje eu
vim contar pra vocês aqui a diabetes é
um pouco da minha rotina o que é
diabética essa é uma pergunta que todos
se fazem após haver doação do diabetes é
uma doença caracterizada por valores
elevados de açúcar no sangue
quando descobri que eu estava com uma
virose
aí fui ao hospital fazer alguns exames
quando os médicos viram que eu estava
com uma taxa de glicemia alta no meu
sangue me diagnosticaram diabética tipo
de diabetes existem dois tipos de
diabetes
o diabetes tipo 1 que é o que eu tenho
que é o mais raro entre as pessoas com a
doença que é o dependente de insulina
isso é deve tomar insulina e diabetes
tipo 2 que normalmente é caracterizada
por sedentarismo e obesidade que a maior
parte das pessoas com a doença têm é é é
um ou quando o pâncreas produz pouca
insulina hoje quando eu quando ele
produz mas não usa ela adequadamente o
que ensina a insulina é um hormônio
produzido pelo pâncreas que permite a
entrada de glicose nas células que é
seja transformada em energia
minha rotina sempre de manhã o tamanho
mais fina que a judia inteiro que e após
cada refeição eu te amo é uma semana
para corrigir o valor da minha glicose
pode na escola sempre as pessoas me
perguntam você não pode comer o cs não
pode comer aquilo eu posso só que depois
de de comer eu tenho devo corrigir o
valor da glicose e insulina e nos dias
por exemplo que eu faço esporte eu
sempre vou levar um anti comigo porque
é a meta de corte pode baixar muito
sintomas é quando eu tenho fobia cns a
glicose baixa eu fico meio tonta e
nivelado e quando eu tenho e plc minha
que a glicose alta eu fico bem irritada
eu uso um sensor que foi lançado na
europa no ano passado e é uma grande
inovação para a vida do diabético por
que você não precisa ficar né furando de
toda hora pra medir a glicose é só você
passar o aparelho e pronto já mediu
conclusão hoje em dia a vida é muito
mais fácil para o diabético porque
antigamente nem existia medidores de
glicose e as pessoas tomavam em cena em
uma em gestão com agulha muito grossa e
depois de um tempo de inventar uma
carreta de insulina que tem uma agulha
bem fininha e hoje em dia existem bombas
de insulina que após a concluir alguns
cliques você já tem sido injetado no seu
corpo
eu fiz esse trabalho porque com certeza
algum de vocês deve ter alguma parente
ou amigo próximo com diabetes e se eles
precisarem de ajuda algum dia vocês
poderão ajudá-lo
obrigada